Jesse! What's wrong? Grodd he's got my god he havin gorilla
City the name of episode 13 is attacking
gorilla City what the hell is a gorilla
City I so then there are sentient highly
intelligent of alternative energy and
they all live in a city deep in the
heart of Africa your father Gary Wells
went to the gorilla City and is missing
in action
oh she's hoping that the team can come
and with her and help save her father
you mean by voluntarily going to city
super it's very and caitlin and cisco
and julian calendars 2 welcome to the
jungle painting while they're going to
the forest the traps brought appears and
captures them now they're stuck in these
gorilla City cells unable to escape God
stamping their powers the only a lot of
flash across it will be sent to be arena
and executed and so we get to do a flash
gladiator fight in an arena follow
screaming gorillas where are you going
are you going to kind of you know it's
just a city of them might be the
greatest thing I've ever seen on
television needs to be Supergirl best
worst video game
hey everybody it's Charlie we got to
talk all about God we got the new
footage let's break it down
that is some introduction it may be the
greatest thing that I've ever seen on
television before flash vs gorillas in
an arena gladiator-style are you not
entertained everybody's going to be
screaming that during the episode so if
you're new to the channel i do flash
videos every week be sure to subscribe
to get everything in there is a flash
ring giveaway going on all explained at
the end of the video but just addressed
this footage so you see Jesse quick
explaining to them i love how Joe is
always the explainer character he's the
guy who always pipes up when they have
really complicated sciences
hey i don't i don't get what you're
talking about could you please explain
that to me could you dumb it down to
shade the only reason they do stuff like
that it's an old TV trick is just for
people watching the TV show that have
absolutely no idea who God is because
there's like this hardcore fanbase that
knows exactly what's up the thing you
have all these other people the tuna
just like I have no idea what's going on
but that's kind of what my youtube
channel is for so the only bad thing
about this is that we don't see solovar
but they did show up a picture of him
last week looks like it's from later in
the episode or maybe it was a CG test
because there's not a lot around here
but when they showed the big wide pan
shot from last year like with rod seeing
it for the first time that looks like
the arena way down there but i do love
the explainer that he's dampening their
powers he knows how to do that that's
how smart he is and he's speaking
through Harrison well just like he did
through general Eiling the voice actor
that does God actually goes to a lot of
conventions you might be able to get him
to record a phone message for you like
it Grodd as your answering machine
message but I've already done a couple
videos about the premise of the episode
I'm going to do like a top 10 things you
need to know about Gorilla Grodd he has
a really cool back story that's been
changed a couple times and there's a lot
of green lantern easter eggs but number
10 the Big Green Lantern easter egg
he got his powers his mental abilities
from the same meteorite that gave Hector
Hammond his powers from the Green
Lantern comics they wreck on that later
but that was originally flash number 106
in 1959 so it goes way back they also
changed number 9 his origin story he was
supposed to be from a different earth
then later they change that to make him
the disciple of this alien visitor
her so it's really trippy when he
started out in the comics but this alien
ship crashes in that gives them their
intelligence
solovar also becomes his rival gaining
intelligence in the same way so they
kind of become this dichotomy that will
see play out during the episode but
number 8 the alien visitor also
compelled them to create gorilla City
think of it as being on par with Wakanda
compared to other African nations so
much more advanced more beautiful more
in tune with nature something you'd
expect from a group of guerrillas that
are smarter than Jesse quick who's
probably the smartest person on the show
right now
number seven he has all kinds of powers
you've seen most of them on the TV show
already
telepathy mind-control psychic blast but
he's also as a result of his mutation is
much bigger than the normal gorilla
which is part of what makes them
stronger than the normal gorilla
gorillas are very big on their own
they're already really dangerous but you
have to imagine he's like the
Schwarzenegger of gorillas six he
actually became the flashes enemy on
accident he was actually going after
solovar have been captured by humans so
Grodd wanted soul of our powers of my
control for himself so that he could
take over gorilla City and when the
flash heard soul of ours distress call
he came to help in fought off grodd
starting their beautiful relationship as
the worst of enemies number 5 he's
actually gone back in time to try and
white humans out broad time-traveling
that will be the craziest thing ever on
the TV show in son of ambush bug he goes
back and tries to kill them off but the
twist is this is kind of a silly story
and you can see the title of the comic
book here this actually looks exactly
like the flash tattoo world so it's an
icy strait for that the garage goes back
so far in history but he almost end up
wiping out common ancestors of both
gorillas and humans so he's floored when
he realizes that he can't kill them
without also killing himself it's a very
reverse-flash type problem can't get rid
of Barry Allen without also erasing his
existence as the reverse-flash number 4
during jla generations number two he
tried to run central city and run for
governor with a mental control device
that made everybody liked him
there are a couple other things that he
tried to do because it's funny idea that
girl's gonna walk around and try and
actually govern human being
the thing is
the issue was actually written by John
Ostrander from The Suicide Squad
comics so nice deep cut for that number
three
flashpoint rod from the comics actually
succeeded where main universe grodd's
did not he was able to take over the
entire continent of Africa but this is
during flashpoint so you have this
giant Amazon Atlantis war going on
everything's gone crazy the reverse
slashes run a muck but while this is all
going on garage is actually doing very
well during this time line number two
new 52 flash met garage on accident when
the speed for shunted him into gorilla
City so he happened upon him and then
eventually that led to the sequence of
events whereby they had a version of
guerrilla warfare gorillas rushing into
crush central city which is kind of the
threat that we're getting ready for in
this episode but the number one thing
this is really big hopefully they'll be
an easter egg for this on the TV show is
that he created zoom when he broke
hunter zolomon back or directly led to
his creation
we've already done zoom on the TV show
so maybe they'll have an easter egg
maybe some team member will get made in
a way that will cause them to go evil in
the future but we got the new episode
coming tomorrow i'll post my video after
it airs is gonna be crazy
there's also some new Wonder Woman Ares i'm
gonna post you guys have been asking me
for an aries video and I'm thinking
about making Monday's a permanent
spider-man bonus video day like I do
flash videos on tuesdays all the time
let me know what you guys think of that
people way though there is a new round
of the flash ring giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video announce
the winner when i post my flash episode
video while you wait for that suppose
you can click here to learn all about
the vulture on spider-man homecoming and
you can click here we're all about the
flash prophecy
thank you so much watching everyone with
high five of the unique video